uh here's Chuck Todd and as you know
Chuck Todd is being kicked out over at
Meet the Press but I guess they're
giving him a couple more shows to say
goodbye with uh here he is on Biden's
abysmal approval rating
Biden's job rating sits at just 43
percent about where it's been since the
withdrawal from Afghanistan 53
disapprove uh a full 68 of Voters
including 43 percent of Democrats now uh
which is twice what it was in 2020 say
they are concerned that Biden does not
have the necessary mental and physical
health to be present in almost 70
percent of people are going uh yeah this
guy doesn't have it he ain't got it you
either got it or you ain't as Mel Brooks
once said and these mainstream Obama
Democrats right these are the Joe Biden
is the Vestige of the Obama democrat he
was his VP
he's the leader of the party and all of
these people their ideas are bad they
are counter to uh American uh I would
say philosophy and more and more people
are seeing through it and as more and
more people see through it the machine
has to come crashing down on them
because all the machine has is the
ability to lie to defend a bunch of bad
ideas if the ideas were good they would
be rising to the top but they they can
only push their nonsense uh using their
power that's what they can do
[Music]
foreign